Speaker 1: All right, I have something
for you today. That I think some of you
were going to think is funny. But it's really
not. It's actually really, really horrifying.
I don't know how many of you remember this guy,
Stu Peters. We're going to look back at in a bit.
We're going to look back at a clip from a couple
of weeks ago where Stu Peters said he believes
that the flu or COVID that he got was given to
him deliberately like a weapon. And he said that
without any evidence, he interviewed yesterday
an anti-vaccine actress known as Crystal Teenie.
That's Crystal Teenie. Who? I there's no way for
me to say this without just saying what it is.
She claims that when she's near
vaccinated people, she has anal bleeding.
OK. She believes that that symptom is being
caused by people shedding the vaccine onto her,
that it causes anal bleeding. She's a
dancer, model, choreographer, type person,
hairstylist. I think she has hair accessories
and makes yoga elements. And she is anti-vax.
Take a listen to what she had to say. Listen
carefully because she uses coded language,
Speaker 4: sanely alarming clots. Yes.
OK, yeah. Well, that is absolutely
alarming. Have you visited with a doctor, a
physician and talked about this? Or I mean,
are you pretty much have you made up in your own
mind that if you were to go speak to a doctor
that they would tell you that you're nuts, that
this just doesn't happen if it doesn't exist,
despite the fact that it's proven that it does
exist? Several experts have said that. Is that
why you're hesitant to go or have you gone?
Speaker 6: I have not. I have not gone and
people I felt like maybe should go to the doctor,
but I know exactly what they're going to say,
and especially because I am not vaccinated.
They're going to say that has no relation and I'm
not going to waste my time doing that. After all
the research that I've done and I know that you
have done. We do know that there is a relation to
it, and I actually did a video like way back when
at the very beginning when people start getting
vaccinated and noticing problems with their
menstrual cycles and things like that. Now, for
me, obviously there are people getting nosebleeds,
anal bleeding and vaginal bleeding. I will
do the process of elimination. I am not
gradually bleeding or bleeding from the nose.
Speaker 1: OK, so understand what she says,
she says. Some people are getting nosebleeds,
vaginal bleeding or anal bleeding.
I'm not getting vaginal and I'm not getting
nose bleeding. So so she's saying I'm getting
anal bleeding when I'm near vaccinated people.
Speaker 6: The fact that it is something more
serious since obviously women menstruate
and it's really, really scary. So I'm not
going to go to a doctor. It does resolve
over a period of time. It's been almost a
week and I am still experiencing the symptoms.
Speaker 1: So guys. If she I'm not joking around
here, if she's telling the truth. This could be
colon cancer. It could be a bunch of other things.
It's I if she's just lying and saying being near,
she's not even saying these are side effects
from getting vaccinated, she's saying these are
side effects from being near vaccinated people
when she goes near a vaccinated person. She has
anal bleeding for a week and then it resolves,
she says. If she's lying, then it's crazy. If
she's telling the truth, she really needs to be
evaluated. I mean, I'm not kidding around, and
this is maybe the craziest show I've ever seen.
This is a reminder of when Stu Peters claimed
that someone infected him deliberately with the
virus as opposed to like he just caught it.
Speaker 4: I wouldn't be surprised if this
so-called cold, the virus,
the flu that I have right now
was a targeted attack on me. Do you speculate
that some of that might be going on as well?
Right? A targeted attack? Yeah, I mean, absolutely
like the bioweapon being released on you. This
the sociopath. Tony Fauci, when he chimerical
engineered this taxpayer funded lab originated
intentionally released Wuhan China virus.
Speaker 1: And I should make clear just
so we don't get any in any trouble
on YouTube. The claims being made
right now by Stu Peters are untrue.
Speaker 4: I mean, that can probably
be used against people automatically. I mean,
people, Republicans, conservatives, talk show
host people being targeted with this virus.
Speaker 1: Anyway, you guys get it. He caught a
virus against which he was not vaccinated, and
he says it must have been a targeted attack.
Really scary stuff. If these people really
believe this stuff, then they do need to
be medically evaluated. If they are just lying,
then it's extremely immoral what they are doing.